téchiné encore cette fois-ci ce sont les
concurrents anglais et allemands qui
demandent à la communauté européenne
d'enquêter sur les conditions de
l'installation de son usine dunkerque un
projet en collaboration avec l'edf lyon
drôle d'huissier il cambriole une
planque d'action directe brûlent des
documents qui auraient pu servir à la
justice trois hommes et un serrurier
sans ce soir en prison recherche
médicale grâce à la culture de cellules
5 millions d'animaux qui chaque année
serve de cobaye à la médecine ont
peut-être une chance de sauver leur vie
enquête dans ce journal madame monsieur
bonsoir étranges affaires lyonnaises ce
soir trois huissiers et un serrurier se
retrouve en prison accusé d'avoir volé
du mobilier de l'argent des armes et
plus grave brûlé des documents
appartenant à l'organisation terroriste
action directe documents qui auraient pu
servir à l'instruction du dossier
comment sont ils arrivés là simplement
parce qu'en 1986 trois mois après
l'arrestation d'un membre d'action livre
direct andré olivier ils sont appelés
par la propriétaire de l'appartement a
constaté un défaut de paiement de loyer
et pour cause d'officiers de justice il
se transforme alors en voleur et déclare
que l'appartement est vide
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
isabelle steiss philippe duval au
deuxième étage de cet immeuble un petit
deux pièces 30 mètres carrés à peine la
planque d'action directe ou de 86 depuis
quelques mois la propriétaire de
l'appartement ne touche plus de loyer
elle mandate alors le cabinet carette et
petitjean pour une procédure d'expulsion
trois huissiers se rendre sur place avec
un serrurier derrière la porte des
documents des armes et cent mille francs
d'argent liquide
ils viennent de découvrir une des bases
logistiques d'action directe
les trois huissiers ne la laisse pas le
parquet
disparaître les documents et se seraient
partagé l'argent six mois plus tôt la
branche lyonnaise d'action directe avait
été démantelé son idéologue alain
ollivier était arrêté jeudi dernier le
juge bruguière perquisitionné dans les
locaux du cabinet carette et petitjean
les trois huissiers été interpellé
aujourd'hui l'un des associés exprime
son étonnement je suis stupéfait fur et
à mesure que j'apprends des nouvelles
dans cette affaire et je sais ce sont
des faits qui je pense ne peuvent pas
t'expliquer de la part de personnes
comme ça mais malheureux confrère
il avait peut-être la réputation d'être
un peu arrogant ou peut-être un peu
suffisant mais sans plus des hommes
chargés de faire respecter en quelque
sorte la loi qui se mettent hors la loi
c'était c'est très grave
c'est ce cas plus graves à mon sens hier
soir les trois missiles ont été inculpés
de vol destruction de preuves et faux en
écriture ils ont été écroués et risque
la cour d'assises encore pechiney ce
soir mais cette fois ci la taxe vient
par l'intermédiaire de la communauté
européenne de bruxelles de ses
concurrents anglais et allemands qui
demande une enquête sur les conditions
exactes dans lesquelles pechiney a
bouclé le dossier de l'installation de
son usine de dunkerque
réalisé en collaboration avec edf projet
annoncé en même temps que le rachat de
la société américaine american can le 21
novembre dernier
pour jean vandois le pdg de pechiney il
s'agit là d'une manoeuvre de concurrents
jaloux tout est parfaitement en ordre
les précisions de claire chazal
cette fois c'est sûr la future usine
d'aluminium de pechiney qui doit être
installé ici à dunkerque pour 3
milliards de francs que la commission
européenne s'interroge aujourd'hui
certains concurrents de pechiney en
europe aurait en effet porté plainte
pour concurrence déloyale
estimant que pechiney avait reçu trop
d'argent de l'état et payer son
électricité trop peu cher bruxelles
demande donc à l'état français
d'expliquer son rôle précis dans la
sphère l'état actionnaire ne fait que
d'autres et pechiney d'un milliard de
francs 89 souligne rue de rivoli qui n'a
d'ailleurs encore rien versé et df
explique quant à elle avoir passé un
accord de partenariat avec pechiney et
ne pas lui vendre son électricité au
dessous du prix canadien nos concurrents
européens sont jaloux répondre enfin en
substance les responsables de pechiney
déjà malmené par les soupçons de délits
d'initiés qui entoure le rachat de
triangle il était de fait des proies
faciles pour leurs voisins anglais ou
allemands à faire pechiney encore et
toujours sur le terrain politique cette
fois depuis le début des révélations le
premier ministre monsieur michel rocard
était resté silencieux hier dans un
discours prononcé à la roche-sur-yon il
a réagi
pour la première fois et sur le mode
polémique rappelant les scandales qui
ont émaillé le septennat de monsieur
giscard d'estaing et notamment l'
affaire des diamants
réaction immédiate de l'ancien président
de la république dans un communiqué très
sec accuse michel rocard de vouloir
faire oublier par la bassesse et la
diffamation
son inaction et son silence cette
polémique intervient à un moment où l'on
pensait que toute la classe politique
était d'accord pour attendre les
résultats de l'enquêté de la commission
des opérations de bourse commentaires
gilles mais le silence observé par
michel rocard depuis le début des
affaires commençaient si je puis dire à
faire du bruit
le premier ministre est donc sorti de sa
réserve hier d'abord pour exercer le
rôle traditionnel d'un premier ministre
dans la vème république à savoir de
protéger d'abord le président de la
république ensuite pour faire taire
certains reproches socialiste relatifs à
cette discrétion
michel rocard a donc développé la contre
attaque sur un ton très offensif un peu
à contre image mais après tout d'une
somme qu à six semaines des élections
municipales en tout cas un durcissement
net qui correspond à un choix pour le
gouvernement de reprendre à tout prix
l'initiative d'abord en rendant public
le rapport de la commission des
opérations de bourse
ensuite en refusant tout amalgame entre
pouvoir et entourage enfin en engageant
le fer avec l'opposition
une position qui par la voix de valérie
giscard d'estaing parlait ce matin de
bassesse et de diffamation tout cela en
attendant le vrai rendez vous politique
dès la semaine prochaine
ou quel que soit le contenu du rapport
de la cob le gouvernement devra gérer le
dossier sur le terrain de la vérité et
de la transparence
même si ce fameux rapport nous laisse
sur notre faim voilà je bouclerais ce
dossier ce soir avec un sondage sondage
bva pour le compte du journal du
dimanche à paraître demain est réalisée
jeudi et vendredi dernier au beau milieu
des affaires donc 43% des personnes
interrogées contre 27 estiment que
monsieur mitterrand a une part de
responsabilités dans le déroulement des
affaires pechiney et société générale
47% impute une part de responsabilité à
monsieur bérégovoy 34 à michel rocard
enfin 39% pensent que ces affaires
peuvent affaiblir durablement le chef de
l'état 38% pratiquement le même
pourcentage pensent le contraire saint
pierre et miquelon contre saint malo le
face à face s'est terminée aujourd'hui
par un accord signé entre les pêcheurs
bretons et le premier ministre à l'hôtel
matignon les malouins conserve le droit
à un quota de pêche de 5500 tonnes de
morue dans la zone de l'île de saint
pierre et miquelon
mais s'engage à retirer leur deuxième
navire qui s'apprêtait lui à pêcher sur
place cet accord comporte par ailleurs
dit on des clauses gardée secrète
elisabeth et cela après quatre longues
heures de négociations ce matin à
matignon on a enfin abouti à un accord
dont le détail des modalités restent
confidentiels mais les professionnels de
la pêche n'ont pas caché leur
satisfaction
c'est un bon accord qui assure la
pérennité de l'entreprise et l'avenir de
l'entreprise à moyen et long terme et
c'était ça c'était indispensable pour
notre que on obtenu pratiquement tout ce
que nous avons demandé rien de bien
précis de la part de la com à pêche
quant au ministre de la mer hachée qui
s'était élaboré dès hier soir les bases
de l'accord il reconnaît timidement
qu'il s'accompagne de compensation
financière il y a bien entendu volet
financier mais c'est surtout mon souci
qui est celui de poursuivre l'activité
de la grande pêche métropolitaine c'est
mon voeu c'est mon souhait mais ceux de
la sema volonté et celle du premier
ministre michel rocard
pour le sénateur maire de saint pierre
albert peine les démarches malouines ont
été avant tout une quête de subventions
il reproche aux pêcheurs métropolitain
de n'avoir pas su s'adapter à
l'évolution de la grande pêche dès
l'annoncé de la signature de l'accord à
saint malo les cinq grévistes de la faim
ont cessé leur mouvement
quant à lécluse du port bloqué depuis
hier par des manifestants elle a été
rouverte en début d'après midi le trafic
alors repris progressivement mal reçue
par les enseignants le ministre de
l'éducation nationale monsieur lionel
jospin avait changé aujourd'hui
d'interlocuteurs il est allé cet
après-midi parlé de son projet de
réforme et de revalorisation du métier
d'enseignant à des lycéens réunis en
congrès à créteil et qui appartiennent à
la fédération indépendante et
démocratique lycéenne sur place jean
brahmi frédéric passer des lycéens bien
sage pour accueillir lionel jospin
ministre de l'éducation nationale venu
plancher devant les délégués du congrès
de la fédération indépendante et
démocratique lycéenne
après les grèves et les manifestations
de professeurs hier lionel jospin s'est
adressé au dessus de la tête des jeunes
aux enseignants
j'ai personnellement porter jugement et
jugement de condamnation sur des mots
d'ordre qui consiste à faire la
rétention des notes à ne pas donner les
copies parce que je pense que là dans
une vie scolaire qui est déjà
suffisamment angoissant parfois
suffisamment insécurisante je pense
qu'on peut pas jouer avec ça on peut pas
jouer avec ces phénomènes d'incertitude
sur plus d'un dialogue timide s'est
instauré entre les délégués et le
ministre chacun respectant son rôle
lionel jospin en magistère les lycéens
en bon élève attentif et puis ensuite
j'en ai parlé d'une rémunération au
mérite alors on n'a pas très bien
c'est pas ma philosophie que de faire ça
au mérite et certainement pas la tête du
client et certainement pas les chefs
d'établissement chargé de dire quels
sont les bons et quels sont les mauvais
professeurs simplement dans un certain
nombre de cas pour des raisons
financières
il n'est pas possible que tous les
enseignants progresse dans les nouveaux
grades où ils auront des salaires
supplémentaires tous en même temps
alors eh bien il faut déterminer un
certain nombre de ceux qui le feront
mais il faut le faire sur des critères
objectifs en fin de journée le ministre
semble être heureux ces lycéens et
l'organisation avait appelé à la
manifestation d'hier qu'en pensez vous
et oui ça je crois que aussi ce qui
concerne leurs enseignants les
concernent
moi aussi d'ailleurs c'est pourquoi j'ai
l'esprit ouvert par rapport aux
propositions que j'ai fait voilà elle
veut donc dire que vous risquez de
modifier la loi m hu dans sur l'avenir
faits divers en bref maintenant et
pilotes dans la sphère des irlandais de
vincennes trois hommes que l'on avait
cru appartenir à l'organisation
terroriste de l'ira et chez qui en fait
les gendarmes du gign avait en 1982
déposée de fausses preuves de leur
culpabilité bien ces trois irlandais
viennent d'obtenir aujourd'hui un franc
symbolique de dommages et intérêts six
personnes interpellées à nice est accusé
d'avoir commis plusieurs attentats
contre des foyers d'immigrés sonacotra
de la côte d'azur et contre des locaux
de la cgt et du parti communiste depuis
le dernier attentat en date c'était en
décembre dernier à cagnes sur mer
il avait fait un mort et 11 blessés dans
un foyer sonacotra justement sur ces six
personnes une à partis au front national
les autres à des organisations comme le
parti nationaliste français et européen
est un groupe qui se fait appeler france
avec sa police médecine et économie tout
à la fois il s'agit d'une découverte
très importante je pense pour les
aveugles des lunettes auditive qui vont
leur permettre de percevoir directement
et très distinctement des sens et des
éléments du monde de la lumière
celui qui est le nôtre c'est un médecin
installé dans un petit village des alpes
maritimes qui a fait cette découverte
reportage marque maisonneuve claude
sicard dans la lumière douce du matin
calme
d'un village plutôt tranquille une vie
qui échappent à ce qu'ils sont aveugles
car le monde de la nuit les condamne à
n'avoir que l'écho de la vie murray dans
le bruit des autres être aveugle
signifie bien souvent ne connaître que
les qu'une des choses pires antonetti
billy a cherché et trouvé un moyen
d'identifier les objets par ceux qui
n'ont que la nuit la femme d'un de mes
amis venait de mettre au monde des amis
médecin venait de mettre au monde son
bébé dans une clinique de nice et tout
s'est merveilleusement passer le bébé
était là là là on était dans l'euphorie
et elle a demandé à son mari elle a
dédié à son étude devrait ouvrir la
fenêtre alors il tourne et grédy qu à
chaud elle a dit non non mais c'est à
cause de la fumée elle devenir veulent
quelques heures après l'état veulent une
embolie du kazma et il avait déjà un
problème d'un côté une embolie du
classement de l'autre côté elle est
devenue aveugle définitivement et je
crois qu'elle n'a jamais vu son bébé
alors ça nous avait beaucoup touché on
s'est dit mais peut-être nous
reconnaissons pas la lumière ne sachant
absolument pas se diriger
peut-être que ça pourrait l'aider de
fabriquer un petit système qui permet de
reconnaître la nécessité léman terre
c'est pas une grande invention
alors on a fabriqué dans une boîte de
dans une boîte d'allumettes un système
électronique qui était reliée à cellule
est au centre de la monture une fibre
optiques reliés à des composants
électroniques dans chacune des branches
de lunettes une prothèse on dit il c'est
l'intensité lumineuse qui en variant
délivre des informations sonores aux non
voyants
pour lui la possibilité d'acquérir un
vocabulaire de son une ouverture sur le
monde
l'espoir d'éviter l'autisme chez les
enfants ce système permet un enfant
aveugle de sortir le matin et de dire
monsieur y faire le temps magnifique
aujourd'hui la droite par contre il ya
des nuages
il peut dire la maison en face de nous à
quatre étages
il voit le ciel au dessus de la maison
il voit à droite le vide lumineux à
gauche la maison à deux étages et ici il
ya des arbres seulement voilà pire
antonetti a beau avoir une superbe idée
les difficultés se succèdent deux
sociétés chargées de la mise au point
qui ont failli en groupes industriels
qui accueille chaleureusement le projet
sans jamais donner suite le dispositif
attend patiemment les propositions des
de 30 mille francs
créer une petite unité usines puissent y
ait de quoi acheter le dentifrice pour
les employés il s'est écoulé 14 ans
depuis l'élaboration du premier
prototype ses lunettes opto dytique sont
toujours française par la volonté de
leur inventeur et grâce à son
opiniâtreté les premières devraient être
vendus aux environs de 3000 francs
juillet 89 une bonne chose pour une idée
révolutionnaire la politique étrangère
maintenant c'est essentiellement ce soir
la pologne après des mois de face à face
des dizaines d'heures de négociations eh
bien les représentants de l'ex syndicat
solidarité avec les chevalets ça à leur
tête sont parvenus à un accord avec le
pouvoir pour ouvrir une table ronde dont
la date a été fixée au 6 février
prochain bruno le bref de dures journées
nous attendent et cela m'effraie un peu
avertis lech walesa pas de triomphalisme
donc après que la reprise des
négociations entre le pouvoir et
solidarité lui permis de fixer enfin une
date pour l'organisation d'une vaste
table ronde entre les deux parties est
au sol les représentants des syndicats
officiels ne participeront pas à ces
négociations le chef de solidarité est
sorti hier soir très fatigué d'une
longue journée de discussions il a
cependant confirmé qu'il défende est
toujours une position bien précises
il n'y a pas de liberté sans solidarité
le reste tout le reste est donc
négociable il s'agit en particulier pour
le syndicat interdit de savoir quel prix
il est prêt à payer en échange de sa
légalisation
une question sur laquelle la très
remuante base de solidarité restent
divisés
j'en reviens à parler d affaires par un
détour par l'italie dont vous allez tout
de suite saisir le sens en français la
presse qui depuis quelques semaines
s'activent autour des affaires là bas le
célèbre acteur ugo tognazzi qui joue le
rôle d'harpagon dans la pièce de molière
l'avare a trouvé un moyen bien à lui de
dénoncer un scandale qui met en scène
actuellement un homme politique italien
celui ci d'ailleurs furieux menace mais
pour l'instant et bientôt le net
il continue de jouer de rome notre
correspondant marcel trillât franco
nicolas dit un ancien ministre
un personnage nouveau dans la
distribution de l'avare de molière du
moins dans la version qu'en donne
actuellement
ugo tognazzi au théâtre eliseo de rome
et assure tony a dit qu'ils jouèrent pag
on a un peu modernisé les costumes et il
compte quelques libertés avec le texte
intraduisible à une heure de grande
écoute un avare à l'italienne en quelque
sorte
mais c'est surtout vers la fin du
quatrième acte que les choses se gâtent
lorsque tognazzi à prague on qui vient
de découvrir le vol de sac à sept des
100 parmi le public et se met à
suspecter tout le monde
vous êtes tous complices vous avez tous
quelque chose à voir avec le vol ou et
nicolas dit encore nicolas dit l'un des
politiciens les plus célèbres d'italie
surtout depuis l'éclatement au grand
jour de la célèbre affaire des prisons
en or massif au printemps dernier
ministre des travaux publics de 79 à 81
nicolas dit alors secrétaire général du
parti social démocrate est accusé
d'avoir touché près de 10 millions de
pots de vin fournisseurs de cette manne
bruno de miku patron d'une entreprise de
milan en échange de ses largesses on lui
attribuer tous les chantiers de
construction des fameuses prisons en or
sans aucun appel d'offres public informé
de son succès involontaire chaque soir
au théâtre elysées aux francos nicolas
jim menace la semaine dernière de porter
plainte pour diffamation
pourtant tognazzi persiste que voulez
vous c'est plus fort que lui au métier
c'est de faire l'acteur et le show je
peux faire c'est de faire rire et
molière mais non mais non cassure
incroyable pour
pour faire rire et d'un moment que quand
je dis ce bon ce dont le public est gris
tellement fort et il donne un
applaudissements dans la salle
je peux pas refuser parce que pour moi
un applaudissement c'est le pen qu'on
peut dire c'est jeu mais vu les dessins
si par hasard la justice nous interdit
de le faire
qu'est ce que vous avez fait moi si je
me l'interdis ml sous le faire vous
allez à présent moi je peux faire faire
la pièce tout le monde alors au lieu de
le dire jeudi les airs 7 points là je
peux pas dire ça d'ailleurs l'ancien
ministre a bien tort de prendre les
choses au tragique puisque à l'acte 5
lorsqu harpagon on trouve son bien il
s'excuse de l'avoir accusé injustement
pardon pour ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure vous êtes tous innocents
y compris nicolas dit après la comédie
humaine on change radicalement de sujets
dans un pays comme la france qui compte
plus de 9 millions d'animaux domestiques
cette information ne peut pas passer
inaperçu de plus en plus de médicaments
en effet pourrait être expérimentée sans
avoir recours à des animaux cobayes et
cela grâce à des cultures de cellules
auquel s'intéressent d'ailleurs
plusieurs grands laboratoires
pharmaceutiques il faut savoir qu'à ce
jour en france environ 5 millions
d'animaux sert chaque année à la
recherche en quête de catherine grenier
bompard et alain payet pour ou contre
l'expérimentation animale
certains contestent l'utilité et en
dénonce l'aspect cruel d'autres pensent
qu'elle est irremplaçable
un conflit qui dure depuis près d'un
siècle et qui s'est exprimé de façon
violente ces dernières années à travers
des commandos dans les laboratoires
pourtant nos technologies d'avant-garde
pourrait nous dispenser d'une grande
partie cette expérimentation animale à
l'inserm de rennes les professeurs
christiane et andré guillouzo sont parmi
les premiers au monde pour la mise au
point de techniques de culture de
cellules hépatiques qui permettent de
tester de nouveaux médicaments et
produits chimiques comme vous le savez
une fois une dizaine d'années pour
développer un médicament et ce
médicament on l'obtient en testant
environ 3000 molécules sur animaux et
bien et il est vraisemblable qu'à partir
de cultures de cellules en particulier
un tir de culture de fat aussi des
cellules hépatiques
il sera possible d'éliminer la majorité
de ces deux 1999 molécules sans avoir
recours à l'expérimentation animale
nous avons donc des tests simples peu
coûteuses fiable et reproductive
le ministère de la recherche a pour la
première fois l'année dernière accordé
un budget de deux millions et demi pour
le développement et la validation de ces
méthodes par validation il faut entendre
leur reconnaissance par le législateur
indispensable pour leur application
officielle une étape très longue et très
coûteuse mais néanmoins avantageuse
puisque la recherche privée importante
consommatrices d'animaux donne le temps
de la reconversion dans son effort de
d'innovation thérapeutique rhône poulenc
a décidé également de construire un
institut sur la sécurité du médicament
vous voyez ici la maquette qui sera un
des principaux instituts de recherche de
méthodes alternatives en europe vu qu'il
comprendra à peu près 3000 m² de
laboratoires consacré aux cultures
cellulaires mais je crois que malgré
l'effort que vous voyez là c'est bien
entendu toute la communauté non
seulement française scientifique
française et européenne voire mondiale
qu'il faudra mobiliser pour arriver à
valider ces tests et les faire
reconnaître une pro du législateur si
les manifestations violentes contre
l'expérimentation animale ont permis une
première prise de conscience aujourd'hui
les défenseurs des animaux passent à une
deuxième étape positive qui est
l'encouragement des méthodes
alternatives
c'est la première association qui pour
une fois enfin ouvre le dialogue avec
des scientifiques avec le pouvoir
législatif pikes a pour ambition de
mettre au concours des bourses pour des
chercheurs qui vont travailler sur des
méthodes alternatives concernant
l'expérimentation animale
je crois qu'il faut que chaque français
se sentent concernés si aujourd'hui la
disparition de l'expérimentation animale
peut paraître encore utopique
elle ne l'est plus tout à fait
maintenant pour demain seul homme qui
est en question maintenant ce week-end
en france l'ordre de malte et la
fondation raoul follereau organise une
quête pour la lutte contre la lèpre une
maladie qui touche encore aujourd'hui 15
millions de personnes à travers le monde
principalement d'ailleurs dans les pays
sous-développés il faut savoir
aujourd'hui bien cette maladie peut se
guérir grâce à des médicaments ou à la
chirurgie à madagascar
une religieuse noire américaine
chirurgien est une spécialiste de ce
type d'opération qui permettent aux
lépreux
d'éviter le stade ultime de leur maladie
reportage de notre envoyé spécial jean
claude haye
que l'on ne s'y trompe pas dans cet
hôpital de campagne du sud de madagascar
on ne fait pas que de la petite
chirurgie tous les opérations sont
effectuées aujourd'hui chères marlène
opère un lépreux de 48 ans sur marlène
une religieuse et toute une histoire
personnelle
elle est dans le monde la seule femme
chirurgien plasticien de couleurs
originaire des états unis depuis 20 ans
elle s'est mise successivement au
service des lépreux en afrique
à bornéo puis à madagascar tout près de
fort dauphin à 1000 kilomètres de
tananarive
elle pratique sous nos yeux une ne
relisent c'est à dire une décompression
chirurgicale du nerf du bras son patient
est atteint de la maladie de hansen
si on ne perd pas son mal va s'aggraver
et la griffe des doigts caractéristiques
de l'affection l'épreuve à apparaître
maestria calme sur marlène où le docteur
marlène comme on veut fait autorité
partout où elle passe elle enseigne dans
les hôpitaux universitaires de
madagascar et va opérer partout où l'on
demande sa compétence et surtout son
amour des malades
vous réalisez votre projet votre rêve de
vie de jeune fille
quelques minutes de détente maintenant
avec la bande dessinée le festival
d'angoulême vient de se terminer
la nouveauté de cette année bien c'est
finalement l'intrusion de la bd comme on
dit dans la littérature traditionnelle
dans les faits les premiers romans
illustrés viennent de sorties reportages
de nos envoyés spéciaux pascal deschamps
maryse richard pierre christain annie
goetzinger l'écrit elle dessine des
bandes dessinées mais dans leur dernier
album le tango du disparu à deux bulles
un texte illustré derniers nés d'un
mariage récent le roman et la bd fut de
plus en plus d'adeptes
alors est-ce qu'il tentait d'ailleurs
c'était pas tellement de renouer avec le
roman illustré que j'ai beaucoup bébés
et enfants mais plutôt de chercher des
choses qui se rapproche aussi bien du
magazine par exemple c'est ce que j'ai
fait un peu dans los angeles avec bilal
des cinq ou six ans qui se rapproche
aussi je dirais du cinéma c'est à dire
de concevoir un livre comme un montage
exactement comme montré une bande son
d'un côté comme on fait une bande images
de l'autre
et d'essayer de mélanger tout ça
les dessinateurs se lance et s'attaque
même aux classiques céline illustrés par
leur dit jules renard relu par fred la
polémique s'installe
les puristes accuse les dessinateurs de
bd d'utiliser les écrivains pour
rechercher une véritable reconnaissance
littéraire
les dessinateurs protestent de leur
bonne foi et c'est de respecter vraiment
l'esprit de sid jules renard j'ai
surtout pas voulu trahir donc c'était
très c'était beaucoup plus compliqué que
si j'avais travaillé sur un an mais
propres textes où on peut moduler enfin
faire selon ses sentiments puis on peut
se permettre de changer un mot ou
presque la jules renard j'ai rien changé
bien la virgule près c'est 6 à trois
points de suspension il ya trois points
de suspension mais vrai quel qu'il soit
passons sonic une une vision
y'en aura beau si on a déjà eu ce pas
définitif et puis pour les éditeurs
concernés l'intérêt du roman bd et
d'avenir à la littérature un nouveau
public
pour preuve ce test réalisé dans une
grande surface au rayon bande dessinée
il s'est vendu trois fois plus voyage au
bout de la nuit illustré par tardi qu'au
rayon littérature générale
on chausse les skis maintenant à la
veille des championnats du monde qui
vont avoir lieu dans le colorado aux
états unis et qui vous seront d'ailleurs
je vous le signale au passage retransmis
intégralement et en direct sur antenne 2
présentation donc des meilleures chances
françaises y en a deux carole merle
franck piccard lionel chamoulaud voici
l'équipe de france de ski filles et
garçons au grand complet
un an après calgary on attend la
confirmation des espoirs entrevus au
championnat du monde à vail colorado
les deux plus attendus sont carole merle
et franck piccard carole merle c'est le
symbole de la progression est de la
bonne forme du ski féminin tricolore
carroll a déjà enlevé la coupe du monde
de super g en où elle est souveraine
on compte sur elle dans cette discipline
et puis elle devra aussi s'attaquer en
géant à l'imbattable vreni schneider est
également à la descente
un sacré programme pense qu un précieux
allié de toute façon qu'on fasse des
résultats ou non il suffit de la
supporter mais je vais la voir en
descente et en géant et en super géant
mais je me sens assez forte à supporter
à gaza depuis même si pour l'instant
carole et sur la plus haute marche
elle n'est pas seule le reste de
l'équipe est très solide en revanche
chez les garçons les résultats sont plus
décevant notre champion olympique franck
piccard blessé et opéré au genou ne sera
peut-être pas tout à fait prêt à
kitzbuehl la descente test franck
termine loin très loin et le moral en
prend un sacré coup là pour faire dans
les quinze noeuds là pour faire dans les
dix dans l'es5 et puis on se retrouve
loin c'est navrant tu resterais me
confiant pour la suite
voilà une confiance timide en tout cas
chez les garçons les stars seront tomba
ghirardelli et zurbriggen depuis 1931
date des premiers championnats du monde
l'autriche domine avec 43 médailles la
suisse en compte 38 la france on a
remporté 23
on en attend d'autres à partir de demain
ne peut pas dire ça soit un oui est un
espoir franc et massif on va parler du
tiers c'est maintenant mais ça
s'arrangera lundi tiercé qui secouerait
cet après midi et que vous avez
d'ailleurs pronostiqué
pierrette brès bravo hein 7la ce que
m'ont dit oh non mais comme disent les
turfiste et le système rapportent 2008
105 francs et 50 centimes il y à un
quarter également vous ajoutez le 15 et
là vous gagnez 19 1714 offrant et 80
centimes voilà ce journal est terminée
tout de suite après les prévisions météo
avec josé dans la pierre ensuite aux
alentours de 23 heures 20 et bien
philippe gassot vous donnera les
dernières informations et en attendant
vous avez le droit et le devoir même de
regarder champs-elysées où vous verrez
ce soir l'invitée vedette c'est le
monsieur qui a une petite fawcett et qui
se trouvera là où menton et qui se
trouvera aux côtés de michel drucker
quelques de glace bonsoir bonne soirée à
demain 13
non